Variational quantum eigensolver atau VQE adalah salah satu algoritma hybrid quantum klasik yang paling awal dan ini
menarik karena beberapa alasan. Pertama, seperti yang akan kita lihat dalam video ini, ini adalah pendekatan yang menjanjikan untuk beberapa jenis masalah. Kedua, ini penting
secara historis dan telah membuka jalan untuk banyak algoritma yang ditingkatkan seperti adapt VQE.
Dan akhirnya, VQE cukup sederhana. Mudah dipahami apa yang dilakukan komputer kuantum dan klasik dalam algoritma ini
dan bagaimana mereka berinteraksi. Ada empat komponen utama dari perhitungan VQE.
Pertama, ada operator, seringkali Hamiltonian, yang akan kita sebut H, yang mendeskripsikan properti sistem yang
ingin kamu optimalkan. Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah kamu mencari vektor eigen dari operator ini yang
sesuai dengan nilai eigen minimum. Kita sering menyebut vektor eigen itu sebagai ground state.
Berikutnya, ada ansatz yang berarti pendekatan. Ini adalah quantum circuit yang menyiapkan state kuantum yang mengaproksimasi
vektor eigen yang kamu cari. Sebenarnya, ansatz adalah keluarga quantum circuit karena beberapa gate dalam
ansatz diparameterisasi. Artinya, mereka diberi parameter yang bisa kita variasikan. Keluarga quantum circuit ini
bisa menyiapkan keluarga state kuantum yang mengaproksimasi ground state.
Berikutnya, kita butuh estimator, sebuah cara untuk mengestimasi nilai ekspektasi dari operator H atas state kuantum variasional
saat ini. Kadang-kadang yang benar-benar kita pedulikan hanyalah nilai ekspektasi ini, yang
kita sebut cost function. Di lain waktu kita peduli tentang fungsi yang lebih rumit yang masih bisa ditulis mulai dari
satu atau lebih nilai ekspektasi.
Akhirnya, kita membutuhkan optimizer klasik, algoritma yang memvariasikan parameter untuk mencoba meminimalkan cost function ini.
Mari kita jelaskan masalah yang ingin kita selesaikan dan pendekatan umum sebelum membahas bagaimana kuantum berperan. Kita
bisa merumuskan banyak masalah optimasi yang penting bagi sains dan industri sebagai masalah nilai matriks. Umumnya, kamu
ingin nilai eigen minimum dari matriks kamu dan vektor eigen yang sesuai. Matriks H bisa berupa
Hamiltonian yang mendeskripsikan energi dari sistem fisik. Dan nilai eigen minimum akan menjadi energi ground state
E0 dan vektor eigen akan menjadi ground state kuantum yang sesuai yang sering dinotasikan sebagai psi sub 0.
Atau matriks bisa mendeskripsikan cost function yang rumit yang terkait dengan masalah optimasi kombinatorial
seperti dalam logistik dan eigen state s subopt akan menjadi solusi optimal dari
masalah seperti string biner yang memberi label cut dalam graf jaringan distribusi. Dalam praktiknya,
umum mendengar istilah Hamiltonian digunakan untuk semua matriks yang diminati bahkan di luar ilmu fisik. Katakanlah
kita tertarik pada matriks dengan n baris dan n kolom. Masalah-masalah seperti itu bisa diselesaikan dengan cepat dan tepat menggunakan
solver klasik untuk n hingga beberapa ratus atau ribu tanpa asumsi yang dibuat tentang matriks. Untuk
matriks jarang, yaitu yang sebagian besar entri nolnya, ini bisa jauh lebih besar dengan n setinggi satu miliar bahkan di laptop.
Tapi untuk masalah yang benar-benar sangat besar yang melebihi angka-angka ini, metode aproksimasi atau heuristik seringkali diperlukan.
Semakin besar matriks dan semakin tidak jarang, semakin sulit masalah dan semakin banyak trik cerdas yang harus digunakan. Misalkan matriks kamu begitu
besar sehingga diagonalisasi eksak bukan merupakan pilihan. Misalkan lebih jauh lagi kamu tahu cukup banyak tentang masalahmu sehingga kamu bisa
membuat beberapa tebakan tentang struktur keseluruhan dari state target dan kamu ingin menjelajahi state yang mirip dengan tebakan
awal kamu untuk melihat apakah cost atau energi kamu bisa diturunkan lebih jauh. Ini adalah pendekatan variasional dan ini adalah satu metode
yang digunakan ketika diagonalisasi eksak bukan merupakan pilihan menggunakan komputer klasik. Ini akan bekerja sebagai berikut.
Pertama, kamu membuat state tebakan dengan beberapa parameter theta yang akan kamu variasikan.
Meskipun tebakan awal ini bisa acak, itu tidak disarankan. Kita ingin menggunakan pengetahuan tentang masalah yang ada
untuk menyesuaikan tebakan kita sebisa mungkin.
Kedua, kita akan menghitung nilai ekspektasi dari operator dengan sistem dalam state tersebut.
Ketiga, kita akan mengubah parameter variasional dan mengulangi.
Keempat, kita akan menggunakan informasi yang terkumpul tentang landscape dari state yang mungkin dalam subspace variasional kamu untuk membuat
tebakan yang semakin baik dan mendekati state target.
Prinsip variasional menjamin bahwa state variasional kita tidak bisa menghasilkan nilai eigen yang lebih rendah dari
ground state target. Jadi semakin rendah nilai ekspektasi, semakin baik aproksimasi kita dari ground state. Mari
berbicara tentang kesulitan dari setiap langkah dalam pendekatan ini.
Menetapkan atau memperbarui parameter secara komputasi mudah. Kesulitannya adalah dalam memilih yang berguna secara fisik
parameter awal yang termotivasi. Menggunakan informasi yang terkumpul dari iterasi sebelumnya untuk memperbarui parameter sedemikian rupa
sehingga kamu mendekati ground state adalah non-trivial. Tapi algoritma optimasi klasik ada yang melakukan
ini cukup efisien. Optimasi klasik ini hanya mahal karena mungkin membutuhkan banyak
iterasi. Dalam kasus terburuk, jumlah iterasi mungkin berskala secara eksponensial dengan n.
Langkah tunggal yang paling mahal secara komputasi hampir pasti adalah nilai ekspektasi dari matriks kamu menggunakan
state tertentu. Matriks n kali n harus bekerja pada vektor n elemen yang sesuai dengan orde n kuadrat
operasi perkalian dalam kasus terburuk. Ini harus dilakukan di setiap iterasi parameter. Untuk matriks yang sangat
besar, ini memiliki biaya komputasi yang tinggi. Sekarang bayangkan mendelegasikan bagian perhitungan ini ke
komputer kuantum. Daripada menghitung nilai ekspektasi ini, kamu mengestimasi dengan menyiapkan
state s dari theta pada komputer kuantum menggunakan ansatz variasional kamu dan kemudian membuat pengukuran.
Mari kita urai sedikit. H umumnya tidak mudah diukur. Misalnya, bisa terdiri dari banyak
operator Pauli x y dan z yang tidak komutasi.
Tapi H bisa ditulis sebagai kombinasi linear dari suku-suku H sub alpha yang masing-masing mudah diukur. Misalnya,
operator Pauli atau kelompok operator Pauli yang komutasi bitwise. Nilai
ekspektasi dari H atas state S adalah jumlah berbobot dari nilai ekspektasi dari suku-suku konstituen H alpha.
WEBVTT
Ekspresi ini berlaku untuk state s mana pun tapi kita secara khusus akan menggunakannya dengan state variasional s dari theta.
Setiap suku h alpha bisa diukur m kali menghasilkan sampel pengukuran s sub alpha j dengan j berjalan dari
1 sampai m dan mengembalikan nilai ekspektasi dan standar deviasi. Kita bisa menjumlahkan
suku-suku ini dan mempropagasi kesalahan melalui penjumlahan.
Ini tidak memerlukan perkalian skala besar maupun proses yang secara pasti berskala seperti n kuadrat. Sebaliknya,
ini memerlukan banyak pengukuran pada komputer kuantum. Kalau kamu tidak membutuhkan terlalu banyak, pendekatan ini bisa menjadi
efisien. Dan itulah bagian kuantum dari VQE. Tapi mari kita bicara tentang alasan kenapa ini mungkin tidak efisien. Satu alasan
untuk banyak pengukuran adalah untuk mengurangi ketidakpastian statistik dalam estimasi kamu untuk perhitungan yang sangat presisi tinggi.
Alasan lain adalah jumlah string Pauli yang diperlukan untuk merentang seluruh matriks kamu. Karena matriks Pauli ditambah
identitas merentang ruang semua operator dari dimensi tertentu, kita dijamin
bahwa kita bisa menulis matriks yang kita minati sebagai jumlah berbobot dari operator Pauli seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya. Di sini C alpha adalah
koefisien numerik dan H alpha adalah string operator Pauli yang bekerja pada semua qubit yang mendeskripsikan sistem kamu.
H alpha akan memiliki bentuk seperti ini di mana operator Pauli ke-n dari kanan bekerja pada qubit ke-n. Jadi kita bisa
mengukur operator kita dengan mengukur serangkaian operator Pauli. Tapi kita tidak bisa mengukur semua operator Pauli tersebut
secara bersamaan. Operator Pauli kecuali identitas tidak komutasi satu sama lain kalau mereka
terkait dengan qubit yang sama. Misalnya, kita bisa mengukur I Z IIZ dan ZZ
XZ secara bersamaan karena kita bisa mengukur I dan Z secara bersamaan untuk qubit ketiga.
Dan kita bisa mengetahui I dan X secara bersamaan untuk qubit pertama. Tapi kita tidak bisa
mengukur semua Z dan ZZ ZX secara bersamaan karena Z dan X tidak
komutasi dan keduanya bekerja pada qubit ke-nol.
Jadi kita menguraikan matriks H kita menjadi jumlah Pauli yang bekerja pada qubit yang berbeda.
Beberapa elemen dari jumlah itu bisa diukur sekaligus. Kita menyebut ini kelompok Pauli yang komutasi. Tergantung pada
berapa banyak suku yang tidak komutasi, kita mungkin membutuhkan banyak kelompok seperti itu. Sebut jumlah kelompok-kelompok Pauli yang komutasi tersebut.
Sebut t.
Kalau ngcp kecil, ini bisa bekerja dengan baik.
Kalau h memiliki jutaan kelompok, ini tidak akan berguna. Kamu mencatat nilai ekspektasi atau cost function
untuk set parameter theta yang digunakan dalam state kamu dan kemudian kamu memperbarui parameter dari waktu ke waktu. Kamu bisa menggunakan
nilai ekspektasi atau nilai cost function yang telah kamu estimasi untuk mengaproksimasi gradien dari cost function kamu dalam
subspace dari state yang diambil sampelnya oleh ansatz kamu.
Optimizer klasik berbasis gradien dan bebas gradien keduanya ada. Keduanya menderita dari masalah trainabilitas potensial seperti
banyak minimum lokal dan wilayah besar dari ruang parameter dengan gradien mendekati nol yang disebut barren plateau.
Jadi apakah VQE akan menyelesaikan semua masalah terberat kamu? Tidak. Tapi lebih baik di semua perhitungan tidak pernah menjadi tujuannya. Kita
telah menggeser apa yang menentukan biaya komputasi. Lihat apa yang sudah kita tukarkan. Kita telah beralih dari proses
yang kompleksitasnya hanya bergantung pada dimensi matriks ke proses yang bergantung pada presisi yang diperlukan dan jumlah
operator Pauli yang tidak komutasi yang membentuk matriks. Bagian terakhir tidak memiliki analog dalam komputasi klasik.
Berdasarkan ketergantungan baru ini untuk matriks jarang atau matriks yang melibatkan sedikit polystring yang tidak komutasi, proses ini
mungkin berguna. Ini adalah kasus untuk sistem spin yang berinteraksi. Misalnya, untuk matriks padat, ini mungkin menjadi
kurang berguna. Kita tahu, misalnya, bahwa sistem kimia seringkali memiliki Hamiltonian yang melibatkan ratusan, ribuan, bahkan
jutaan polystring. Telah ada pekerjaan yang menarik untuk mengurangi jumlah suku ini, tapi
sistem kimia mungkin lebih cocok untuk beberapa algoritma lain yang akan kita bahas dalam kursus ini.
Penggunaan VQE yang efektif juga mengharuskan kita mengetahui atribut dari state target kita dan bisa memilih state awal yang baik secara fisik
termotivasi serta ansatz yang baik dengan parameter variasional yang relatif sedikit. Ini bisa menjadi
cukup menantang. VQE mendemonstrasikan bagaimana kekuatan komputer klasik dan kuantum bisa digabungkan
tanpa menambahkan metode-metode yang lebih baru. VQE tidak membantu kita menyelesaikan masalah yang tidak dapat diatasi oleh komputer klasik, tapi
terus memainkan peran dalam pengembangan algoritma. Dan VQE juga mengajarkan kita bahwa mentransfer langkah dari komputer klasik
ke komputer kuantum bukan lebih baik maupun lebih buruk untuk semua tujuan. Sebaliknya, ini
mengubah faktor-faktor apa yang menentukan efisiensi algoritma kamu. Ini adalah pelajaran umum yang penting dalam komputasi hybrid
quantum klasik.